hello everyone the time has come to find
out who where where we all started or
incest or ancestry if you will
this is ancestors the humankind Odyssey
I'm John Luke I'm joined by Jake Jake
you've been playing a little bit of this
right a little bit yeah I started a game
played a couple hours we're gonna start
a new game from the beginning for you
guys we're gonna call this the GameSpot
lineage cool yeah we're allowed to show
a little bit of the game off so we're
just gonna dive right in
also we want to make clear that you saw
the beginning in the bottom corner this
is a preview build of the game not the
full release so if you see any weirdness
it's because it's the preview built so
in the beginning but yeah I did die once
played about that yeah well we'll see
how it goes
you know this game is a like
procedurally generated or is it a fixed
I think it's a fixed world or a fixed
map we'll find out though it was kind of
hard to tell just because it rive really
dense forests but but the area I wasn't
very narrow not like super narrow but it
seemed like almost like a narrow open
world and you went one way and you were
safer and then you went the other way it
was like you're going into the unknown
which is kind of interesting yeah like I
guess I'm curious if how like does it
start you in a random spa or like yeah I
guess we'll find out is everyone gonna
have like a different experience playing
this game or is it a it sounds like the
it looks like the way you can evolve
would probably be different from other
people
so maybe the experience will be
different but it seems like your goals
are still to a ball right cuz I think it
is based on like experiences you've had
right so yeah like you encounter a
particular animal or you die or
something happens to you in that like
instills a certain evolutionary trait
yeah that's kind of the impression I got
like I said I didn't play enough I think
to really see how all that stuff panned
out
but I mean it was giving me like little
things in the HUD saying saying things
like you've got a new trait after I mess
up or do something correctly or I think
was like a neuron has connected
the big bird
does he take your kid Oh No
I thought we were gonna I thought we
were playing the big one but we're
playing the kid mm-hmm I said to my
expectations I'm knocking it down
so wire is like my intelligence this is
where I can see hiding spots now your
eagle vision up there could be a hiding
spot and then if I hit X that's my sense
of smell although it looks like I can't
really do it in this part do they want
us to just learn about intelligence
that's funny I kind of see the the
connection to like the original
Assassin's Creed where do you remember
like the first game they kind of made it
where like the idea was the face maps
each represented like a different part
of the body yeah there's like the head
was eagle vision and then like X is like
your arm and you know you you definitely
kind of get vibes like that like you can
I
I see the influences of Assassin's Creed
like you can tell it was made by Patrice
or one of the people who made it
all right series hiding in this little
we've hidden mm-hmm oh there it is
there's the neurons
there's the neurons oh so you know
switch to a different person yeah now I
got to find the kid I decided to play
without tutorials at first not a good
idea
oh really because it is not a
conventional control scheme okay so
maybe maybe stick with tutorial at least
for like to start out maybe turn them
off eventually I mean I the game as they
kind of set up front in that opening
text if they're not gonna hold your hand
so outside it seems like the tutorials
are gonna be there to teach you how to
play but they're not necessarily gonna
yeah tell you what to do okay you're
fine so I found out that there is
falling damage but like not a lot of
falling damage
I imagine maybe that's just too hard
like you would just fall and then there
still is though like you'll keep you
from falling like break bones and stuff
oh that's interesting
oh so I don't know it's attacking me
well I doubt there's something snake oh
there it is I see it
barely the snakes sneak up on you
because I can hide in the bushes and all
of a sudden this that's what snakes do
man
no I see you're on day two years zero oh
yeah I know
Wow oh where was it I thought I saw I
hear him yeah he's screaming me a little
too loud
something's gotta know somebody oh there
we go there's a snake again oh yeah I
can hear him
[Music]
this is that supposed to be him the
think so hmm right yeah yeah cuz that's
the the roll rock right oh right ah yes
ah my mom used to comfort me I don't
know I don't know I'm comforting him
listening come here kid
you're like timing it with like his I
don't know
it's kind of cute yeah I like that it's
like he follows you around now you on
your back yeah I picked another one up
and I didn't know how to like get them
off by baby like all right your neurons
are growing probably do some climbing
yeah I want to know about right right
you can climb pretty much anything as
long as it's like a smooth surface yeah
and I can like I can hang on to foliage
and whatnot but stick it up nice and
high today I'm talking about there we go
oh wow so yeah it seems kind of narrow
at least at this point but the further
you get the the more like like
essentially your your monkey will have
like an anxiety attack for being so far
away from like learning I have to like
build up it's like Oh God
you have to like build up its oh geez oh
we're good you have to build up his like
confidence in in uh like courage in
order to get further out interesting
that's kind of their way of like
naturally gating you yeah it seems like
it I bolted as far as I could
immediately and I couldn't see anything
and the screen starts to turn really
dark and there's all these like figures
that show up like the like in your head
I guess oh we get we can head on there
after this yes I will end it oh
something's going on this was fun
alright can your lineage of all faster
than our ancestors did probably not well
actually probably cuz didn't that take
millions of years yeah he will do it in
three dates yeah
like get some food haven't heard the
water say assuming if your character
dies you then like swap to a different
yeah person like a different member of
your clan then food discover I
discovered what water is now sweet you
like you should already known that one
drink the water here we go there we go
got some water
alright I'm food so like whenever you
pick up something new you hold X inspect
it and you can kind of decide at what
it's used for it'll give you a hint that
way you use it for this is food we're
gonna eat this
all right and the other thing we need to
do is sleep - but I don't need sleep
right now
can you like decide if you're gonna be
more vegetarian versus uh I don't know
I've only found like like plants to eat
and fruit I haven't been able to like
kill anything I'm not entirely sure how
you go about that because it seems like
you can only really dodge oak odd I mean
you know again we mentioned we don't
really know how far this goes
intentionally I think you know that is
seemingly part of like the fun of the
game is figuring it out yeah kind of
like where it's gonna go but I would I
would like to see you know I'm not
expecting it to be like this game is
gonna end with you in like modern days
but like in a son it's just food on TA
or something but I think I think I just
broke something with that no but I'm
curious if like oh you can like learn
how to carve Spears or build fire yeah
yeah I'm kind of curious to see how far
it goes I know you can like make beds
and stuff because oh well the more you
can get laid some other you can bang
humankind Odyssey I know
okay so this is we're about to the swamp
area where my character was like nope
not okay that's not even that far no
let's do a little bit of climbing this
even find some food like what's that
little radar in the bottom center that
has to do with your like whether you're
well-fed sleep okay okay just I like
green means good I think so okay yeah
like I'm not 100% clear on all the UI
neither am i neither am i oh come on
jump off Oh God not like Oh No
so yeah I just broke a bone on purpose
we want to show it yeah I was planning
you know okay we got some water down
here
doesn't look like clean water
I like that animation this leg meant
water source takes a tongue kind of you
all tastes that's cool alright stagnant
water so it's probably isn't the best
for us but I think I got to find some
food if I only heal up or just like wait
a long time about that a snail with this
snails are good for you right
he knows no I don't think he likes it no
you thinking about it
new food to stay true to it alright
let's eat it hope it's not poisonous
Rock too sick no it might have been
alright let's eat the frog it might have
been poisoned yeah just eat the Frog
that's also probably not poisonous I
can't eat the Frog can't pick them up
whatever oh that's it going
oh I got sick yeah see like so that
little those fangs in the corner mean
I'm poisoned so I guess I shouldn't eat
the mollusk and the other thing is my
broken bone so it'll heal over time I'll
just take my I can always just sleep and
I don't like recover it oh yeah okay
yeah so I hear the unknown so you use
your senses intelligence to identify
what's around you like you were saying
eventually like your character couldn't
really see much like you just died or
yeah he's a life are Mike because I'm
I'm afraid dopa me as well warthog
dopamine is needed to avoid hysteria
and then there's the light that's like
how that's like follow light to get out
of here
got it
Oh can't grab on to that
Oh Oh God oh Jesus run
I even hurt
this is going well for you decided it
wanted to snack on a state a snake
instead I guess we're safe he got a oh
[Laughter]
alright now get out of here this is no
good no good your characters getting
cold too from the rain Izzie oh yeah he
is huh okay well your bone healed so
that's good you got that but I'm
bleeding and cold can you is there any
way to know where your your bike plan is
broken ah yeah you lose my senses I'll
tell you where they are accepted though
I think it's one of those up there maybe
we should just go back to bed
yeah maybe it's time I want to drink
some water though
got some water
they get on back god I just think my
bone finally healed can you switch to
another if I die I can only if you die
you think there might be maybe there's a
way later on or maybe there's something
I'm missing but when I was playing
earlier I fell off a very big tree
obviously and died and it switched me to
do another one
we'll make it
promised there
yeah a pie Oh see my I think I need to
eat and sleep
oh it's like you're yeah oh yeah we're
struggling here boy
and clearly I am far worse than our
ancestors worth this
we're almost there though maybe we can
make it no shrinking you shrink it all
we're gonna die
what happens when it goes all the way
down I think I just I think I'm just
gonna die my husband on the kid
oh boy oh boy just give back home we
believe in you you're so close right
yeah I'm calling them you can hear oh
boy the wasps struggle oh is it food
here though no yeah it's a coconut no
maybe maybe you could yeah yes yes yeah
eat it
I can't eat it do I have to like break
it open
hmm that seemed to help though yeah it
did help yeah a little bit your meter
back oh ho that was calculated I knew
I'd be fine
c'mon
oh come on get up get up get up there
did I go too far I don't know well the
camera right up happening with the
camera here oh boy oh yeah I think it's
down there oh okay
watch me die
he just land yeah there there we made it
maybe you still seem pretty bad [ __ ]
gotta sleep but can you work in the
arrest oh there we go there you go
oh boy it's probably about as good as
place Danny stop that was a journey it
was let's see then I dream are you
dreaming look at that like snake attack
oh look the things that happen maybe I
don't
okay
what I think I died cuz I was bleeding
out and didn't heal though oh no I was
hoping sleep would solve it but sleep
will not sleep doesn't cure yeah a
bleeding wound and now I switch there we
go well that's a bit of ancestors can
you find your body oh that's a good
question yep oh he did not make it oh
wait I can interact with it but you will
analyse neuron energy for other actions
weird all right well this game I mean
you know the the 25 minutes we spent
with this is to be honest barely enough
time to scratch the surface yeah it
seems like it's got some interesting
ideas definitely have to play more
though to figure out yeah unfortunately
that's pretty much all we're allowed to
show yeah it's kind of a bummer I am
curious to see how far this game goes
might get me to yeah well anyway thanks
for showing us Jake yeah I appreciate it
and Ancestors comes out in a couple
weeks right yep cool all right so yeah
thanks for watching guys and if you're
interested in more videos about
ancestors or any other games then please
stay tuned the game spot